in this video we'll talk about
competitive Elisa
so competitive Eliza also known as
inhibition Eliza is an assay to detect
antigen in a quantitative fashion so
what does this assay measure this assay
measures the concentration of antigen by
detection of signal interference we'll
talk about this in bit more details
but what is the principle of this assay
as the name suggests the principle is
comparative binding
and what is the advantage of this assay
this is extremely sensitive and adequate
for low levels of antigen in a patient
sample
so let's look at the equipments that are
required for this particular assay so
obviously you need a 96 well micro
writer plate some pipettes and other
reagents obviously the patient serum and
then up Elisa Plate Reader which would
detect the color development
so first step is to isolate the serum
and incubate the serum with
antibodies so you want to know that okay
whether this particular antigen is
present or not so obviously you create a
monochloral antibody against it and
incubate the patient Serum with that
antibody
now in this scenario what would happen
is if there is the antigen present in
the patient serum then the antibody
would potentially bind to these antigens
now depending upon how much antigen is
present in patient sample there would be
uh selective binding right so in this
case you can see there are antibody
bound fractions and there are antibody
which are free
now the next step in the Elisa is to
coat the wells with a reference antigen
this is the same antigen that we want to
detect from the patient sample
now then we put the serum and antibody
and this is where this particular Elisa
is different from other Eliza in other
Eliza we just put the syrup
but here we
incubate with the antibody and then put
the serum
so in the serum plus antibody fraction
there would be bound and Unbound
antibodies so the bound antibodies
obviously cannot bind to the reference
antigens right because they are already
preoccupied now there are Unbound
antigens so these Unbound antigens so
and Unbound antibodies would go and bind
to the reference antibodies now after a
wash these kind of bound fractions would
be removed and the primary antibody
would be binding to the reference
antigen present in the well of the Elisa
plate
then obviously secondary enzyme-linked
antibodies would be provided followed by
chromogenic substrate which would
provide a colored product so obviously a
color reaction would be developed in
this Wells and one can detect this color
reaction
now how this is quantitative in order to
understand that let's take two situation
in first situation we can see a lighter
color is developed in a second situation
we can see a darker color is developed a
darker color is developed because there
were more substrate to product
conversion and this is possible because
there were more antibody bound enzymes
so from this particular scenario we can
understand in case one
there are more uh bound antibodies and
very less free antibodies
so as the free antibodies were less not
much enzymatic reaction could take place
but in the second situation there were a
lot of free antibodies and very less
antigens
and that is that is why lot of
antibodies has bound to the reference
antigens lot of secondary antibodies has
bound to the primary antibodies and lot
of color reaction happen that's why your
darker color is developed so moral of
the story by looking at the color we can
understand whether the antigen is more
or antigen is less now let's say you
have a standard using the standard you
can get a sense of exact concentration
of the antigen in the patient sample so
overall what we learned this particular
comparative Elisa technique is pretty
sensitive
it can detect very low level of antigen
and it is highly quantitative it can
tell us not only whether an antigen is
present or not but it can also tell us
how much is it present is it present at
a low level or a higher level so I hope
this was informative and useful
get more notes and flashcards in my
Facebook page or Instagram page link is
provided in the description
and you can support our Channel using
super thanks or even in patreon see you
in next video